[Music]
[Applause]
the break room uh our daily live show
here at new rockstars where we talk
about all the nerdy news of the day
we're broadcasting as we always are from
our actual break room here at new
rockstar's headquarters in los angeles
california that's right we're thrilled
to have you here today um
and we have so much to talk about last
night into today has been a huge day for
content we had miss marvel premiere
obi-wan kenobi episode four we had a new
uh black adam trailer our first kind of
extended peek at that character we also
under all of that we got some more
thor footage even that's like the fifth
biggest thing that happened right we
have a thor footage so we're gonna dive
into all of that
and i'm gonna do that here with my good
friends mr brandon barrick oh hello this
is to you the rock all right i don't
care about dwayne johnson you've made
your movie it's done i want to see you
at wrestlemania next year hollywood
california even though it's at sofie
stadium which is not in hollywood but
they're gonna claim it's hollywood
california you better come back rock
okay wow
come on the show you coward
uh jessica clemens this is also a
message to the rock uh
it's just marrying me already
he's technically single right no he's
married now
he has a child he has two children i
think okay hey don't be putting the rock
out on blasphemy hey marry me okay yeah
and then uh
mr john costa joining us
what's your message to them this is this
is a message to
my pet rock from my fourth grade class
i'm sorry
i didn't take care of you and you died
oh
you killed it rock i killed a rock and i
feel guilty my parents jettisoned it out
of our volvo uh in the in the eighth
grade at another driver yeah they said
it was long enough this dead rocket i
feel bad for the miata that that hit on
the way out what was he was there yes uh
that's why my parents set a mentoring uh
oh god as we uh often do here on the
show we have a swear jar going on okay
and again uh we appreciate everybody in
the chat everybody uh responding to
polls that get placed in there and
everybody that's sending us super chats
and we're so grateful for those super
chats when you do uh contribute a couple
doubloons a couple dinero uh to the old
break room fund that when we hit a
multiple of a hundred dollars it
unleashes the swear jar we're not
supposed to be cursing on this show
we're all good boys and girls here who
obey the rules
uh but
when we get a hundred bucks
those rules go out the door and we
become uh potty mouth sailors
bad boys give me camera four get out and
get him
get out of here
okay
chat
i sit behind the scenes of the show
every day
you guys are so freaking great every day
so gracious to tommy beck told and when
he's not here
we get nothing
we get nothing so now i have to fill in
for tommy not as fun i appreciate that i
understand that
please
please okay all right
get out of jessica's lap it's getting
sad okay
we'll make we'll make john go see
morbius if you play that yes
i was supposed
jessica showed up john had committed to
it backed out of morbid time last
saturday due to some kind of dog-based
commitment that i think is pretty
spurious at best but
how about again there this is the rare
day where we have so many headlines we
can barely talk about anything else so
let's get into what will be the rest of
the episode the headline
yeah baby
see that's
do you want to talk about
miss marvel oh and real quick
we were all just talking about this we
all loved that miss marvel episode oh
yeah last night uh really enjoyed it we
liked it so much we actually don't want
to waste it today we're going to do a
deep dive on ms marvel tomorrow we feel
like we got to jump into the obi-wan the
black adam stuff today and we don't want
to shortchange miss marvel because
there's so much to talk about and we
really really loved it so can we can i
make requests yes just initial
spoiler-free first thoughts from
everyone just so if you haven't seen it
stay with us if you have seen it we just
want i mean i was watching in the office
this morning i'm pointing at you because
you were you you share somewhere you
share an office with me we're forced to
share and i kept i kept pausing it every
five minutes and taking off my
headphones
and looking at brandon and being like
this is great yeah like the visual
stylization of this show is i i told
brandon i think it's like
the best thing since wanda vision
probably as far as just like visual
aesthetic and the kind of stuff they're
doing with way the show looks i loved it
vos talks a lot about euphoria on the
various after shows that he gets to
watch and i i don't want to compare this
to euphoria because they're very
different
euphoria eye makeup but in terms of
euphoria i make i mean in terms of like
stylistic filmmaking and the styles are
different i appreciate that but um i
don't think we have a ton of like hyper
stylized tv to watch right now and and i
really loved that miss marvel was like
taking chances taking risks we saw like
some you know practical uses of how you
would talk to someone on a cell phone
yeah um i don't know i had a great time
and i think people were like skeptical
of this show
maybe they didn't think it was for them
i was sort of one of those people but i
was excited anyways but like
i was telling them yesterday
some of us at new rockstars got a little
early look at the episode and i was
saying i'm more excited for miss marvel
episode two than i was for kenobi
episode four
yesterday i'm
i'm very excited for this show perfect i
didn't get the episodes and i love the
comments so it kind of sucks no but the
my favorite thing about this first
episode is that it's such a young adult
uh show it's more
when she said in her we talked about on
the break room that she compared it to
john hughes to lady bird to scott
pilgrim it is more scott pilgrim than it
is anything plus it's just been so long
to see like i i watch euphoria to get
that experience again of feeling like
i'm in high school
but this one does hit like i'd much
rather go to high school and miss marvel
world than euphoria
i don't know about that did you see that
i didn't see that i did like the play
i'm dressed like
oklahoma um uh i will say listen up
breakers listen up roomies uh
uh yeah like jessica was saying it's it
is definitely like opening up the world
of marvel to a younger generation a new
generation the episode's called
generation y w-h-y but i will say it's a
little more adult than i thought it
would be they say the word cocaine yeah
whoa fir is that first mcu
uh you gotta think douglas back in the
70s was doing a bunch of good yeah
the actor that plays the guidance
counselor if you guys don't know him i
do not know his name but look it up
because he is the funniest person ever
and i think i think but not worth
remembering
no he wrote when the fly landed on the
head during the political debate that
was going on he did a great pr
impression of the fly's manager that was
him he's a great funny
that was a fun scene but again that will
be the sum total of the miss marvel will
cover today come back tomorrow maybe a
lot of you didn't get to watch it two
episodes at midnight can we start a
campaign can we just get belligerent
with disney plus yeah it's ridiculous
that you dropped those episodes at that
time it's also ridiculous you dropped
both of them the same night you could
have given us miss marvel on tuesday
night you could have given us a
smartphone at 8pm pacific i mean amazon
gave us three episodes of the boys on
like thursday at like but it wasn't five
or six pm it wasn't trying to compete
with anything and he was like yeah here
you go
on our own platform because that's my
whole thing is like star wars and miss
marvel are still on the same platform so
why would you do them yes
they're missing out we want to be live
tweeting we want to be seeing people's
reactions in real time and you can't do
that at midnight pacific anyways all
right let's get on to the stuff we are
going to talk about yes let's get on to
black adam yes
i love black adam and we actually the
trailer dropped and we did a live
reaction to it bone-dry
go ahead and play that clip for me
daschle
he looks pretty good
that's dr
oh that's when okay okay keep going son
sacrificed his life to save me oh
no not a baby rod the scorpion king
this has this has some stargate vibes to
it doesn't it is stronger than superman
i've missed the badassery of dc
oh is that kanye west yeah
they just have like a drop ship built in
there's adam smasher
[Applause]
heroes don't kill that fedex
well i do
that was actually
there's a practical effect any of us
facing against the rock
okay you have two choices
you can beat the destroyer of this one
yeah i don't think so tom cruise
keep them bad keep them bad keep them
bad baby
prince of persia roll them up
little mystery machine action yeah
okay
you could tell that was filmed today
because bran and i were wearing the same
shirt but you could tell it wasn't
filmed live because jessica's wearing a
different shirt
i started expanding
i was wearing a different should we all
leave and change we can change back into
our rejection listen to me talk about
black advertising please please switch
and change during zach's segment yeah so
black adam for
like let's just summarize it for those
that don't know and then we'll talk
about it yeah so then mmm uh basically
black adam was a slave on conduct and he
saved his nephew aman from being killed
they ran away but black adam was stabbed
and injured on the verge of death when
they appeared at the rock of eternity
that's where shazam is amman was given
the powers of shazam along with black
adam they shared it basically then once
healed a mom then wanted to bring peace
among kundok but black adam was out for
revenge so he killed his nephew got him
on his powers of shazam freed the people
of conduct but seeing as he misused his
powers the granddad himself shazam
imprisoned him and buried him in a tomb
which is what we could be seeing right
now so there's different um there's
different takes on his origin story
because there's so many different things
he's an old character and he's an old
kid yeah he's a golden age he's golden
age so there's so many places they can
take it but i think uh the new 52 dc's
run is what they're gonna probably be uh
using for this also because it involves
a lot of shazam um and also the
antagonist for this might not even be
everyone's saying the villain is going
to be black adam because he is an
anti-hero he he he kills the innocent
sometimes in ways that he's like eric
killmonger where he's doing it the
justification's there is just not right
you know not all heroes are murderers
but it's that the antagonist might
possibly be a different person it might
be um where
black adam got his powers from shazam
sabbah got his powers from a demon and
so that might be the actual antagonist
it seems like you would make like uh uh
dr fate the antagonist maybe right
that's what see
seems like he'd be the perfect villain
in this i love this trailer and some
people go ahead say what you want to say
this trailer didn't give a lot away it
just gave you pieces that we already
knew that was in it it's like here's the
characters here's more the rock but it's
not telling you who the actual monster
is who the big bad is it's just more
about his journey and i love that by the
way we uh we're gonna be giving our
first kind of thoughts on this trailer
but we do want to hear from people in
the chat what questions do you have what
sort of first impressions did you get
from this trailer we want to know what
you guys thought i i think it'll be
interesting to see which way dc goes
with this film you know we've gotten a
lot of these anti-hero stories from sony
in the sort of spumsy and they've kind
of been like no they're heroes because
there's the same character as a villain
there's a little bit worse we're the
same powers and so
this trailer to me seems like they're
going to be really leaning into the
anti-hero nature of wow emphasis
on hero sure yeah
with an edge uh as opposed to like i'm a
true anti-hero right which is like
obviously
somebody stood me up like it was liar
liar in 1995 and i was on a date if you
want to see zach go off on john full
swears
send in some super chats that's unlocked
and i don't think this trick will work
twice but if we get over 300 dollars
today i will go see more videos yeah
yes he's alive myself i'll go bye
but you know like
morbius was only killing people
accidentally when he didn't you know
have his sort of thirst safety and they
even went out of their way to make those
mercenary bad guys well they're just
called mercenaries
they weren't very nice literally the cop
al madrigal said nobody's going to miss
them
well you know what they say about cops i
won't say it here oh god
and 48 of you are super excited for
black atomic
not 35 is i'm interested that's not bad
okay let me let me try you guys over let
me try winning you guys over the way i
got one over with blackout not only is
this someone that was a slave so
originally it did take place in egypt
they realized that's probably not the
best idea to do so they traded it in for
conduct which is also ironically a real
place but uh
it's a
[Applause]
he was a slave and he was like i'm out
for vengeance because he lost his sister
he lost uh he almost lost his nephew he
lost the nephew lost to mom and dad so
he was like i need to go after them and
while his nephew is like no we need to
bring peace he's like no i have revenge
because it makes you choose between
whether or not he did right or wrong he
killed all of the people that enslaved
them and freed all of them but at the
cost of killing his own nephew to absorb
his powers of shazam and that's where
shazam thought he was wrong
so not only that but also when he does
come to earth and he's like fighting
people he's destroying people that he
think are bad so like think of
capitalism if he went into the person
that owns uh
g e and was like you don't pay them
enough and then punched him in the face
so i was like oh this guy's crazy so
it's like it doesn't seem like
he's wrong does that make sense can i
ask you an unfair question yeah i'm not
super familiar with black adam i haven't
read the comics um is there anyone in
either the dceu or
the mcu or someone that you could kind
of comp his character to uh i would say
superman uh because he needs to go
against superman just like with an edge
and with a history
monger who is like oh he's got it he's
got the right reasons with the wrong
message right this sounds kind of like
sorry no
he has the motive of killmonger but he
has the powers of superheroes and it
sounds a little bit like khaleesi right
yes it's just about the breaker of
change where she goes in she kills all
all the people who enslaved them but
then like cause way more problems and
well because she doesn't kill all the
slaves right masters right and then they
kind of come back at her and so it is
it's like i like that there's nuance
there right like it's it's like uh you
could do right but then how far do you
go and punishing the wrongdoers right
and sorry only side noting because
there's so much that i want to just also
add in there that in the trailer that we
saw we saw hawkman jumping from the
plane we saw adam smasher that's played
by noah centennial centennial cyclone
and dr fate cyclone basically can just
like move things with wind um but she's
a really cool character i'm really
excited to see the actress come in um
she's the one i'm most excited about and
now we don't know how they're gonna be
linked or portrayed in this film we were
kind of debating seems like that last
that last sequence in the trailer with
the van and the the missile that feels
like it's on earth well right no no it's
on conduct so the van that they're in is
actually named after um black adam's
wife in the comics and i saw that in the
trailer and i was like oh that's black
adam's wife in the con comics they own a
place that is on conduct name that same
place they turned
so they have vw's on condoms
it looked like a vw it didn't have the
vw logo so conduct is now overseen by
the inter-gang which is one of the two
biggest like gangs in metropolis and so
they're now running it and they have
high-tech weaponry they have
i don't know like how they get it's
probably because they're one of the two
biggest crime like places i'm sorry i'm
teaching you metropolis but they
literally have so much money and
resources that they make incredible
weapons so they are overseeing conduct
right now so conduct even if it does
look like that it's still very further
in technology but but so we are are
speculating that like all the like the
machine guns we see all that stuff it's
all on an alien planet we don't think
this movie like none of these characters
are gonna end up on earth they won't be
able to interact with the [ __ ] the
shazam we know or the justice league i
think they will i think they will
because in the comics he straight up
chokes shazam out and then gets to has
to fight shazam's family and loses to
shazam's family so i think they will
inevitably have that they have to think
we're getting a shazam
cam in
black adam not in this black adam i
think there's too much in this black
adam movie because also the woman in
black adam adriana plays his wife in the
comics also john i'll say we'll get a
shazam cam in black a damn oh good okay
great all right
transition uh datsun producer johnson
did say a frequent marvel comparison
is doctor doom uh from from to black out
that would be interesting i would
compare him more to
uh dr fate
doctors they both have certificates on
their wall uh could give you a a pretty
righteous uh ear nose and throat this
will be coming out and then we're gonna
have shazam too
at some point so it would be interesting
by the end of this movie
black adam makes his way to earth yes
and kind of like teases that in a weird
way maybe he walks into the cafeteria
he's like everybody's not here this time
i'm going to kill this guy experience
gaming was asking like other than
superman wonder woman or wonder who
could be a cameo
um
i think shazam is bigger right yeah
shazam is the biggest one i just even
freaking
um dodson screaming at me in the chat um
even in um outside of the
black adam the rock has been mentioning
like i just want to fight superman which
honestly ultimately i think is only
producing this movie so he can fight
soon
i mean can we see something like martian
manhunter someone who's like out in
space a green lantern cameo or something
we're seeing the justice the the jsa
it's based off those comics too so we're
seeing a lot of the justice service of
america gang so we could see black
canary eventually or we could see
well black canary's like all right but
like do we know for sure that this does
exist in the same cinematic universe as
the justice league movies the henry
cavill jason momoa of it all it sure
looks like if shazam does then this
probably does they can okay i'm sorry to
keep throwing facts i just love black
adam yeah dude they could do it because
uh
flash flash's movie um is a reason also
why inner gang gets a lot of their
weapons is from uh flash whatever what
did he do
yeah i think that is gonna be if that's
gonna be the dc multiversal yes
opening up portals so maybe maybe this
the way this movie might portray it is
that kondok is like an alternate earth
right that's all very egyptian and
deserty or whatever and maybe those
things get linked maybe there's a portal
something something in like the mcu
right uh throughout the guardians
travels there's very earth-like things
throughout the
the cosmos of the mcu so you know it
just makes things easier
heavy ancient egyptian iconography
iconography but whatever but it's earth
because i saw a fedex store his attire
when he's contained his egyptian attire
the falcon costume we see is aorus and
he's killed by a kopesh kopesh uh i
think it's i thought vw i loved that
that was freaky i think it's jet i mean
think about i think i think his origin
story will be on conduct and i think
he's going to end up on earth
weren't you saying it takes like 5 000
years to get well that's one of the
that's one of the comics and i think
they're going with the new 52 for this
but one of the comics he traveled from
the planet to earth and it took him like
five thousand that's a long movie
it's not real-time
this isn't boyhood okay they don't hit
the show in real time you were saying uh
should i who was that bad guy for him
someone pointed out on the chat that
they have supposedly they've cast
someone else in this the
man who played jafar in the live-action
aladdin
but it could be a twist or it's like
he's not the villain he's just there a
character or maybe he dies immediately i
don't know did i not say justice society
he said service i think oh sorry i'm
insane thank you fray girl for the
correction there unfortunately that
means you have to
the third leave works absolutely well
before before you're uh shamed into
leaving jessica this wasn't the only
one so uh the joker sequel is making way
do we have the picture that todd
phillips posted on him that's my fault
well it's okay it's just it's literally
just the red cover for joker two you've
probably seen it if you're interested in
it
yeah and you see a picture of wacky
phoenix reading it in a very picturesque
what looked like hotel room but uh all
we got was the fact that a script exists
joaquin phoenix is reading it and we got
a subtitle it might just be a working
title this might not end up being the
actual title of the film but it was like
a um foley ado or something like that
i'm not great at french but if you look
up what the um the meaning of that it's
like uh
two ideas or identities existing
within one oh very which is interesting
and has led some people to speculate
harley quinn maybe
i hope not maybe multiple jokers maybe
i don't know what what more i want from
the joker i just want to see storyline
more if it's going off of the first
joker he made i just want the the chaos
that we saw in the city i want that to
happen i also want to see batman's
parents die so
like this leads to him killing his
parents and a very
a movie that i don't think anyone wants
to see great i i i can't wait to hear it
that's a great way to start your pitch
the first movie is like this guy who is
sort of in selly i think we can kind of
all agree um and then sort of like
breaks right we see that
like problematic masculinity and i think
if we do have a harley quinn story like
this these joker movies haven't been
super action heavy but if we had like a
domestic drama
about like gaslighting and relationships
you want revolutionary rounds
that's right yeah i don't that's exactly
what i like no one wants to see it why
did you pitch it i'd love to watch it
somebody was pitching online like and
you know i think we speculated when the
first joker came out that like maybe
this isn't the joker that eventually
fights batman because the ages don't
quite line up maybe this joker inspires
a joker who eventually is the foe for
batman and so maybe the like the two
identities or the two ideas hinted at in
the title is there is like this joker
and a joker he inspires right maybe
maybe arthur is you know imprisoned in
the entirety of this film right maybe
there's a little silence of the lamb's
action where and and then somebody else
is doing joke rest would you joke me i'd
joke
i do actually know todd phillips
assistant uh and he did tell me that
confirmed in this script there is going
to be the line
i'm the joker baby
i was hoping for it's joker in time oh
no no no someone in the chat said how
many times do we have to watch batman's
parents die and i'll tell you not enough
every time after seeing it again in the
teen titans go movie i gotta see it over
30 more times i mean eat the rich right
speaking of things you can eat uh we
want to thank our good friends
your own segway yeah i know i'm terrible
baby you're good friends and gene fuel
actually all formulas are different on
different varieties of g-fuel this is um
not because g-fuel is sponsoring us we
genuinely like this i even i even have
this is a little collector's item i like
to keep on my desk this is a carnage
flavor of g-fuel holding it it's called
it's worth thousands of dollars it's
called red ooze it's got it's got uh uh
carney himself there on it um they made
special flavors for uh multiverse
madness
they have some special flavors coming
out for both thor and for the boys that
we might be talking about on the channel
but would you might
yes we probably will be uh they even
working with the boys it means the g for
the g we'll be talking about the g fuel
we're definitely talking about the boys
you're doing a great job with the boys
underground yeah the boys every friday
jessica
i asked you to leave 20 minutes ago
okay all right john uh but uh most all
that g fuel we're consuming right now is
caffeinated as hell okay that's why
things are a little lit on the set uh
but they also make hydration formulas
that are not caffeinated if that's not
your speed uh all this is to say hit
that link in the
video description g fuel dot com slash
ly slash new rockstar something like
that uh you get a 10 discount screen
thank you john oh there it is yeah it's
right underneath me play hard on that uh
actually it just says fuel dot l-y
john you know we're not enough on it
john where's this did you did you're
working not including the g yeah i
thought that was the week where's the ge
okay
this is why you're not allowed to be on
camera john okay where's the swear jar
at you've gotta you've gotta run a spell
check i don't wanna hear zach go offline
on giants guys
this guy appropriate behavior both left
left me high and drive it wasn't for
jessica i would have been watching
morbius by myself and now he doesn't
even have the decency to our good
friends of g field
the right url uh but you know what you
can be a better friend to us than john
is uh by going to that url via g fuel
you'll get a discount and uh they show
us a little love as well so thank you to
them for sponsoring try both just try
try both of yours try everything
just click in every just just hit hit
your keyboard randomly uh we also want
to shout out we have um the latest
obsession shirt for obi-wan kenobi and
this is the first we've we're going to
have two latest obsession shirts going
on at the same time this is the first
announcement of this on this yes at new
rockstarsmerch.com we're going to have a
miss marvel shirt yeah i think do we
have a graphic
john play that graphic nope that's not
the right one well that's where you can
go to check out yes rockstarsmerch.com
it looks pretty cool it's got a cartoon
uh sort of around a lightning bolt it
looks great it looks good yeah yeah it's
a it's a very cool um design
either one of those shirts when you buy
them you unlock the ability to leave a
special message
for the obi-wan shirt that message will
be shown and or read out loud on our
wikileaks show there it is
look at that shirt
that's a gorgeous shirt it's got kind of
the doodle
the doodle pattern of uh that kamala
likes to to make and all of her art
uh very cool somewhat this is
why am i on the show someone walked into
our office this morning jessica and i
were here she was shooting wikileaks and
they had like a great cool lightning
bolt on the back of their jacket and i
was like who is this random person in
our office that is like here to get
excited about miss marvel and like 20
seconds later they were like hey am i in
the right building and they were fully
not here also don't understand how
people are getting in here
is this my dad i've been looking anyways
listen get yourself our latest obsession
so you can sneak into our office and if
you want to come test our locks our
office is at 45 28. uh
we're in mexico
california uh yeah but and then as i was
saying if you buy that miss marvel shirt
i don't even know we were speculating i
don't even know if it's up on the site
yet but it will be soon then uh your
message can get read on inside marvel
comes out every week with mt and eric
which is our miss tomorrow after show
yes uh they'll be coming out on
wednesday yes wednesday uh speaking of
after shows
we all watched obi-wan last night
brandon you wanted to talk about it oh
yeah i mean we're at episode four we're
over the halfway hump of uh obi-wan we
only got two more episodes uh left this
was uh three huh six total six total
two more episodes left not enough well a
lot of us think it's maybe not enough
right this was a little bit of a bottle
episode where we're only in the
inquisitor's inquisitorium
and this felt like i was playing jedi
fallen order all over again we saw
obi-wan swimming through the waters
coming in choking out a storm trooper i
was really hoping he'd dress up in the
storm yes what a missed opportunity what
a miss opportunity uh we saw a young
girl almost get tortured that was
exciting uh here's a tip for the empire
speed up the table you could get to the
torturing a lot faster those arms like
get me
get to them i didn't know the tension is
an important part of the torture that's
when you squeal that's when you drop
your info as the arms are closed i
didn't like that because that that leads
a little more cadence to when she later
on in her life sees han get tortured on
one of those tables and hears the
screams and she knows well she doesn't
really she knows he's weaker than she
knows he's weak because she she didn't
she didn't but she didn't give it away
uh we saw how bad the empire is that
checking ids when people come in uh uh
and then my favorite moment of the
episode jessica's favorite too was when
reba calls out like there's a man and a
little girl at that time everyone
that trench coat has three kids standing
on each other's shoulders
did look like obi-wan had a very large
tumor on yeah
also visitors inquisitorium put a radar
on your on your uh building put some
guns on the outside and if if maverick
taught us anything you got to be able to
scramble those jets within five minutes
okay get those tie fighters out there
track down some of these speeders
uh but it was kind of a crazy episode
all over the place saw a lot of stuff uh
but my big question is did leia just
throw bail organa under the bus by kind
of calling out that he's on the good
side not the bad when she's like i gotta
talk to my dad first he's part of the
empire well but but he there's no
subterfuge there probably the only thing
bale is hiding is the fact that he went
to a a jedi
in in hiding to help find his daughter
he's a senator he's probably being very
open about his political leanings right
right right right but this do we think
this could lead to the death of mom in
some way
and you're only speculating that because
we don't know if mom's still alive by
the time alderaan goes
you know someone has to die in this show
someone's going to die in this room
right like we know a lot of the
characters are making it out just
because um hey dude do all these
stormtroopers mean nothing to you
in fact
are you are you al madrigal and morbius
nobody's
we're having a conversation before this
about like the clone trooper's armor had
a lot of perks like they had magnetic
boots so they could walk out on the
outside of ship someone had like uh
waterproof helmets like they didn't give
the stormtroopers who have to work
underwater in a building underwater like
waterproof helmets like some sort of
underwater breathing apparatus is the
empire stretched too thin right now is
the armor getting weaker is are the
mechanics getting weaker is that why
they're so beatable by the time a new
hope rolls around i think so and
honestly i'm so boring that this is the
part of star wars that i want to get
into is the accounting because that
building is so bad
the
the which i mean the blaster went
through the window
i was like how are you going to have a
bunch of laser guns in a building but
the glass is penetrable by it and
underwater it was it made no sense but i
really would love to get into it like
get security cameras why are we relying
on these channels
okay uh you know what i did love i did
love that like you know that that
building is is very impressive as we're
like pulling up to it at the beginning
of the episode it looks cool and you
realize like oh there's a bunch of stuff
under the water level right and in fact
when um the game of thrones lady who i
forgot her character her character is
kind of at the computer console right
kind of not so subtly communicating with
obi-wan you can see why you can see out
the window she's beneath the water level
when we saw that room the inquisitor's
room is underwater yeah they're all
they're all hanging out so i mean
obi-wan
and and you're mcgregor i mean this was
this was a good flex episode for him
he's in shape okay we got we got the
back the tank and he's looking he's
keeping it tight and then the swimming
sequence that's definitely him and
swimming uh looked great i love those
shots of the underwater shot and him
just like swimming right by giant shark
looking creatures not giving a thought
to him you know i did love the like
prequels tech that they brought back for
this one of the kind of underappreciated
things from the series that we're
getting is like there are a lot of
people saying like there's only 20 years
from prequels to a new hope how does it
go from you and mcgregor to alec
guinness and they're kind of giving us a
little bit of that he gets beat up
he's getting beat up
also aging is not linear right if you if
you're old enough out there to have been
around a little bit and like maybe see
your friends are the same age guys i'm
71 years old okay
that's why you look so young
it's it's red ooze carnage flavor has
kept me young but no you you see this in
your friends right like sometimes you'll
you'll know somebody for 15 years and
they basically look the same and then
sometimes you don't see somebody for six
months you're like oh my god what
happened they aged fast you know and i
think maybe we could assume the the
events of this series might kind of put
obi-wan through it right right
you know i see i see someone on the chat
pointing out from the previous episodes
like why did the invader just go through
the fire to get obi-wan he could have
done it right very easy to do i really
think that vader is he's having a moment
of crisis right now because he's had ten
years he really wants to kill obi-wan he
wanted to get duel the fates part two
and all he's got is this old wash up man
who can barely fight anymore and he's
pissed and he's sad and he's got to deal
with these inquisitors and they're
messing around and they're lying to him
like i think vader he's just at this
breaking point yeah he's going to lose
his mind i'm i'm not i i will say i'm
not a villain sympathizer i am um i
think i think we're like focused so much
on kenobi's like trauma that like uh
anakin just got out of the back to tank
and it's just like i don't know what to
do with this all right now yeah like
this is a lot right now and i want to
kill him so badly even it seems like as
portrayed on this show the empire's had
an interesting place the empire is not
tilted into full evil yet we're not
blowing up alderaan right like we don't
have a death star yet and they're still
kind of whispering
and so like maybe that's also a bummer
for darth he's like oh i gotta play nice
kind of stuff right like well he's got
to be kept secret like i still think
most of the galaxy does not know about
vader the only people who know are the
planets he shows up on and start
cracking i think he's i think he didn't
go through the fire because he's also a
little
he's got bit of frankenstein
little feelings
i take i take issue with that right he
lives on his apartment
he got over it he got over it but i was
like i'll do lava but the fire
we did we did a little prediction
yesterday uh most of my predictions
were sadly mistaken nobody got geeked on
spice come on i'll hold out hope for
more yeah future yeah
i think that the head security officer
was geeked out on spice yeah because he
was doing his job he's like i'm [ __ ]
i'm high as hell
show me you show me your your
your papers who are you and then she
called him out and he's like
tell him how he knows
i'm literally gonna make everybody call
me by sir going forward oh yeah she did
that i was like this
badass okay this is so cool that's not a
swear badass is not that's right that's
that's right um
i was gonna say one of the predictions
we all kind of had is like oh rupert
friend's gonna be on kimmel yeah
no grand inquisitor i can't say too that
we didn't get to yesterday
rupert fred was going out in an
interview saying like yeah we get to fly
with our lightsaber they do that like
cool like the the
helicopter
yeah he was like oh yeah we could get
out of the show we haven't seen it yet i
think he's gonna be a late reveal by
vader to be like
hey reva he's still alive and i hate
your guts and i'm gonna let him kill you
uh and then vader's gonna kill both of
you just because he's vader i didn't i
didn't say it yesterday because i was
scared but i don't agree with you guys
when you guys were like oh he's gonna be
in tonight's episode because he's on
jimmy kimmel and i was jimmy kimmel yeah
when he's on jimmy kimmel i was like
well maybe it's also just the time that
he could do it because that happens a
lot where it's just like because the
other people that were also on jimmy
kimmel that night i was like it's also
like samuel jackson he's not in this
so we don't know
we watched it we watched it we watched
the fourth episode chat's pretty split
on whether we'll see leia's mother die
or not fifty to forty nine percent we're
clearly pushing god here at the break
room we're clearly pushing a dead parent
parents yeah we're talking joker we're
talking star wars what stars are all
about uh if we raise two hundred dollars
in the super chat one of our parents
will be murdered oh my god one parent
get him off of this show
get him off the show just me said you
know jimmy smith would have talked his
way out of that situation
i get a little curse time yeah curse out
john listen here john you mother [ __ ]
how dare you leave jessica and i hanging
dry at the amc burbank 16. oh it's okay
two people is fun three people would
have been a party you son of a [ __ ] oh
my god you know i was sort of banking on
some of our roomies to come and join you
at the afc
the breakers got they got some important
stuff break nation
we have to address this also because
people are putting in super chats for it
and in the comments about the tomb
really quick i do want to do one about
the two why save the bodies also
do you think a man told dude
are they kind of like are they frozen in
amber are they kind of suspended in like
a suspended animation kind of thing
where they can maybe be brought back
okay go and then i will come back why
use carbonite okay
no no but i'm saying later this one
looks way cooler maybe because the
empire used to follow
i don't want to spoil what boss said but
we talked about it in this episode of
wikileaks i'm on it stay tuned it's
coming out it's good if it's not already
on the channel
i'll say a little brief piece is because
you can still get the power from them if
they're not in the carbonite if they're
in the amber so i think he thinks oh
he's like hooked up to a battery yeah he
thinks they're still trying to get oh
they're getting like forced juice out
because also they're clearly mace wendy
is not one
clearly raised windu is not one of the
people i also why would mace window be
one of the people i feel like keep his
dead body for something really big
but also the ones that they killed kind
of like
likely split are the ones that are in
there the ones that are like missing
body parts that got like ruined they're
not in there it's just the jedi they
could keep together it's just heavy to
see little kid jedi
i think that's that's clearly uh riva's
freaking best friend or best friend i
think reba i think the third sister is
still one of the uh young ladies
it's so sad how quick they got that one
because that one still did not age it
was still like she got the helmet so i
think she walks past it every day
internalizing all the hatred of seeing
what he did that's why i still think
riva the third sister isn't really for
darth vader and is not for obi-wan
kenobi she's just angry and she needs to
personally take it out on both of them
yeah and
a youngling army coming to storm vader
is going to have a ton of fun with that
uh
tomb room
uh tomb room of doom um tomorrow in the
in the breakdown of episode 4.
definitely check the new rockstars
channel for that um yeah the grand
inquisitor watch continues his name got
dropped but his visage did not appear uh
now we want to move on kind of the third
big thing that we wanted to chat about
is we got a little bit
uh more thor footage as as we mentioned
yesterday tickets go on sale monday as a
part of promoting that they did release
a new kind of trailer cut it had just
like two little promo two little promos
a lot of stuff we've seen before but
like oh a couple extra seconds here a
couple extra seconds there new dialogue
new dialogue two of the biggest things
that stood out to us we got a lot of um
a lot more guardians of the galaxy
battle footage yeah right it looks like
they and thor uh are like in a full you
know a gun fight on whatever this alien
plane it is there's a fun back and forth
where they're like you said this was
going to be like a vacation or whatever
and he says said it would be like a
vacation
it's a fun kind of quip back and forth
but it looks cool we see rocket uh drax
and nebula all kind of going at it also
like a fun reminder we don't usually get
like power rankings for mcu characters
unless we're doing a big question
episode on them but it is like oh yeah
thor is like oh this is disease this is
fine yeah yeah and all these guardians
like we saw mow
yeah i am not a god yeah yeah uh nebula
is like i've been torn apart i do not
want to go through that again yeah but
that's fun and we think maybe that's
what leads to that that scene we've seen
in in multiple trailers where like
they're kind of getting on a ship to
leave and star lord leaves them with the
you know it's all about your friends
kind of a thing so maybe it's you know
he kind of tricks them into hanging out
a battle ensues and they're like no more
dude we're out you know it's probably
also not fun for thor he needs bigger
threats than what the guardians are
taking on
he wants to go deal with a god butcher
you know those kind of more omega-level
threats and maybe just what the
guardians have to offer isn't enough for
him and he doesn't need the money
that's true he's not a bandit he's not a
smuggler uh well and you mentioning gore
that led to kind of the other
interesting new thing that we got from
this clip was
um
the kind of back and forth dialogue
between gore and thor saying like you're
not like the others and thor saying
because i have something worth fighting
for now that's kind of intercut with a
shot of jane do we think that's who he's
referring to i think it's everyone
because i think that i love that line or
i love that scene where he's like where
i think um
star-lord says something like that to
him is like you have to find something
worth fighting for and he's just like
and it's everybody on the guardians team
so i think he's like this is for
valkyrie this is for jane this is for my
dad this is for loki like this is for
everybody the people of asgard
you see peephole you gotta watch more
new rockstars videos yeah the people the
people of asgard people people people
what what's
the people owner at one point says
asgard is not a place it's a people
and uh anthony hopkins
oh oh okay yeah kind of like how uh
doctor strange is peter porker
peter pork all these fun accents i i
think those lines might be just edited
together in classic marvel fashion like
the trailer making dialogue that doesn't
exist in the movie i don't know yeah
those lines maybe don't come back to
back yeah right i mean i love this idea
that we were kind of talking about
earlier too that thor is like so out of
place and if jane i think we we said
this the other day jane's maybe been
powered up for a while while thor's been
off world and her and valkyrie have been
getting along just fine and like jane's
the one invited to olympus or or
to see zeus because she's the god of
thunder now thor's nothing uh ragnarok
has happened odin's down frigg is down
hell is somewhere out there loki's dead
uh the warriors three are dead that's
all part of the ragnarok prophecy right
so the cycle has kind of reset in a way
there's a new head of asgard there's a
new god of thunder thor doesn't belong
anymore he doesn't he's a man without a
mission yeah he's got to find the thing
worth fighting for and what does he want
to do how does he want to live out the
rest of his years does he want to die
could this be the end of thor good gore
get to thor and then we have thor no
more oh
thor no more here don't you think like
in watching these clips and like
the general arc of thor and jane in the
entire series of films like
you know there will be a little
rekindling of the romance we haven't
seen there's been no smooches in any
trailer right like
the most recent footage is like more
love more thunder a smooch
um but we haven't seen so like don't you
think there's a world where this doesn't
end with like thor and jane together
maybe like what i kind of like what
jessica was just talking about where
like thor discovers like a new purpose
but maybe that purpose is like kind of a
friendship a new family because his
existing family is kind of gone and out
of his life i think they are broken up
and i think it's also because like which
is kind of sad because we've seen it so
much that thor is not over jane but jane
is completely open
she was like what's it been two years he
said eight years he said eight years
girl our kid is in eighth grade by now
our relationship is almost in high
school uh so i think jane is truly like
but she was you know snapped right that
was the thing that jane snapped we think
we think in the script for endgame she
was snapped but that's not we'll find
out for sure the script was wrong about
it uh a.w had a super chat do you think
we'll get a loki appearance in thor you
ran a poll
chat says no 58 yes 41 percent pretty
split mt and i talk about this on big
question which will come out this sunday
i think it would be so odd not to have
loki in this but i think it's going to
be loki checking on thor because loki's
got to deal with his own stuff he's
dealing with the tva but he has the
power to go through time and check in i
think he wants to see how thor is i
don't think he has bigger things to
worry about i think he does but i think
he cares about thor and he wants to know
this is this loki
loki mcu 616 dead
loki variant is the new loki i don't
think he's going to show himself to thor
thor much like wanda has had to watch
his love his brother
live and die live and die live and die
so many times uh and he saw the final
death well i mean in keeping with the
theme of jane being thor do we see lady
loki oh well sylvie little reaction i
but that's a long story for another day
and miss marvel yeah you need to read
the comics
they're very good um
whatever even though we just got you
know four extra seconds total of footage
all of it is more intriguing they're
still doing a very good job not giving
away very much of this plot yeah this
movie is under a month away yeah we
might get another big trailer but or
maybe not maybe we just keep getting
enough clips honestly does anybody need
to be swayed to see this movie no we're
all going to see this movie probably
twice opening weekend okay um we're sold
i'm so excited for this film give us a
black panther two trainers
i told my mom i was like yeah uh thor
love and thunder so excited and she was
like is uh jeff goldblum in it because
that's the only way i'm gonna see this
one
i don't think linda
come on i can't remember where i was
reading this but someone speculated that
there was a shot that might have been on
sakaar so this is small
with like me or uh there is a shot that
kind of looks like it could be yeah and
they were like oh maybe um it's korg
it's korg and it's thor and it looks
like a missile
and someone was like maybe they go to
sakaar to get um beta ray b ray bill who
was the champion
we could get it oh sorry i'm looking at
the super chat someone stole my heart
away with theirs and i can't see it
anymore so maybe we'll come back uh
let's let's shout out a couple of the
super chess thank you to everybody
that's been chatting oh and you know
what it is
swear 30. okay check your watches it's
swear o'clock all right
guess i swear we can i think he should
light up john
i
again
gonna pitch we all we wait for the end
of the show and we give a big sign off
oh yes
i want to cuss out john
yeah yeah we'll wait till the end of the
show and then we'll all rip john and
noah um but we want to shout out a
couple of the folks that this is a great
one uh paintamenti our good uh evil
friend
who almost single-handedly forced me to
go see morbius last weekend thank you
paintamenti who would you all cosplay as
avengers only going to avenger con a big
part of miss marvel's episode one we
might find out on the show on friday oh
what a team maybe a little chat with
themselves ignoring that uh just just
inspiring avengers only also yeah we did
see a loki walking around to the people
of earth loki not a good guy
why are you dressing up as loki maybe
he's been redeemed we never know i don't
know i i did i mean the uh low-key tony
stark is the best costume you just i
mean i belittle this i had a tap light
that i would put under a shirt
and then draw a goatee on my face
because my baby boy face can't grow any
hair uh and i would i would cosplay as
tony stark many times earnest many times
esteban said at the end of the series
obi-wan is gonna get addicted to spice
that'll explain the huge age up spices
it's like space math
when we get to the andor series which is
a few years after this i would like to
check in on opioids just like man
stuff got messed up
i was running around with this kid and
all these people died i choked out a
storm trooper and i drowned him i
drowned all these stormtroopers under
wire
quiet guy won't talk to me
oh my god death sticks
that's great um
adam ramirez i've been waiting for you
all to review doom patrol
i don't know that we're going to get to
it adam um
i i like doing this
i think it's certainly better than a lot
of the cw series they're not my cup of
tea i didn't like the last season this
is me personally and we can talk about
it if you want to adam
i didn't i wasn't that big of a fan of
the last season of doom patrol i lied
into jessica's dmz first person
i didn't say all that yeah
i think for the brendan fraser seance
yeah a little bit right yeah that was
the first like welcome back brendan
pleasure we love you um coming up
come back oh mark genoa's got a great uh
one there just wanted to give my
appreciation for everything you've done
with the break room you all are awesome
you're awesome
thank you this is
give me camera four okay
i know dash was behind the scenes today
um
i always roll my eyes when people ask
for this but i'm gonna do it if you like
the break room hit that like button and
i know it's so easy to do
and and i know i i would roll my eyes
for someone asking it does really make a
huge difference for for this show we
want more people to be watching the show
we have a lot of fun with it so if you
could just hit that yes little baby like
button yeah
thank you john that's a good point and
you know and we just want to say we've
said this before on the show but maybe
this is the first episode you're
watching or maybe you need to be
reminded of it the break room we want to
emphasize is not replacing anything on
new rockstars no we're doing all the
break all the breakdowns all the theory
videos all the ending explains in fact
we're only doing more of that now that
like mt and whitney are doing a lot of
videos eric is doing more videos than
ever it's insane so like don't think
that like because we're making break
room oh now they're not going to cover
stranger things or miss martial
but because we're doing the break room
you'll never see me again number four
um you won't get any other jessica
content but the break room content i
mean she is on the boys underground and
she'll be on with working lanes
you'll probably see her inside marvel
every once in a while
before yes and so all that is to say you
know what we know that uh
you know millions of people watch our
break breakdowns we don't think millions
of people aren't necessarily going to
watch break room this isn't for the full
new rockstars audience
well okay in a best case scenario it
will be but it's it's for a sliver of
the audience that we hope will really
like and we're trying to make it for you
the folks watching and enjoying this
right now we want you to enjoy it a lot
it's a smaller group that has even more
fun with it hey that's good news okay
because this is truly us this is the
kind of show we wanted to make and we're
putting it out there hoping that it
connects with a couple people i just
want to say that uh sergio gutierrez he
thinks the final battle will be obi-wan
versus vader and grand inquisitor versus
riva how about that i like that kind of
how we're going to do all the things
kind of like how we were cutting back
and forth between obi-wan and the back
to tank and anakin in the back of the
tank what if like two different
locations you know one on a volcano one
on on a you know starship or something
like that cutting back and forth between
those two battles
i want like a tag team match where like
vader and inquisitor on one side obi-wan
and reeve on the other then you tag each
other out you know what i don't like
that this you know like those scenes in
every like hospital scene where
someone's like they wake up they'll get
these needles out get them out of me
that is the equivalent to this dang back
to back to tank back to tents op in the
star wars universe
if i could go home look at them it's
also it's in it
we're getting now people sunk in water
come up what's going on
nerf back to things though ever since i
saw uh m empire strikes back as a young
lad i agree with obi-wan don't put me
under water and have me have my eyes
open and people like hey buddy how you
doing in there no i wouldn't get out
immediately
if i had a battery i would freak out
never it would be my it would be my hot
tub i'd be like after a long day joe
rogan probably has a bag
in his compound oh also uh not quite
about the tank but most recent season to
stranger things it was a little uh
floaty water deprivation chamber
allowing for psychic flashbacks whatever
yeah i don't know it's hot right now i'm
tired of people being submerged in water
to heal it's like they're getting
baptized
uh i'm tired of magazines same things
do you think you come out moisturized we
talked about this in bugaboo i mean
because he came out it would heal your
dry skin right it would heal your dry
skin maybe i'll get in the back
christie had a super chat uh loki just
pops in sees jane is lady thor and says
i like her even more a call back to his
line when she punches him and drag
forward
good call back crazy uh yeah um well
speaking of liking it even more we hope
you've liked this episode even more
thank you and if you liked it even more
like it even more yes
good tell a friend why not um thank you
jonathan
tell an enemy even better uh to ruin
their day maybe um hold on thank you
john for joining us uh
we we have a big rest of the week
planned as we said we're talking miss
marvel a lot get your mrs marvel
questions ready for it also um
tommy will be back tomorrow um i will
also be gone what no
no don't don't break any hearts uh and
then you know we got the boys on friday
you might be mentioning that new episode
we'll also have boys underground uh
there's a lot and then we're heading
into the weekend it's a jurassic park
week justin parker i'm sorry
tomorrow night i'm seeing it tomorrow
night 8 30 in 3d if you want to come
join me there's no tickets available
you can give us some spoilers
jurassic park forever can they walk away
from the franchise absolutely not i will
be making a jurassic park when uh
universal allows me to chris pratt seems
to say this is it for him get him out of
here you guys he talks to god he knows
the future you all call me darth jessica
in the chat i'm okay with that
i'm okay with that
this won't be the last jurassic park
that's me doing a gold blow oh okay
i don't know if it was gold but uh it's
been a [ __ ] great show with you yes
we had a [ __ ] awesome time we appreciate
all you sons of [ __ ] uh for joining
us and all you [ __ ] are sons
yeah and all you um [ __ ] sons
i was trying to do the thermal
background
that was great uh thank you so much for
watching thanks for all the folks in the
chat in the super chat we'll be back
tomorrow and friday they're to be big
shows friday's going to get nuts i keep
saying that every day but we're going to
officially get nuts on friday yeah
yeah
how awful is the boys going to be on
thursday night i'm scared to keep
watching that show it depends on how i
feel on friday if we're gonna have fun
or not whether you're watching the boys
might be traumatized
thank you so much everybody have a great
day
[Music]
so
[Music]
streaming
[Music]
it's true
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you